i thought what you did with rogan was so
brave yeah that was so brave
now that was like the alley
yeah you could get the most criticism
and i'll tell you this
i don't know if you spoke cancel me
there we go
uh i don't know if you and rogan spoke
but i was talking to him about it and uh
he said it made him tear up man
i love that dude man and um you know
rogan's a guy that for me
look all right we know what's going on
yeah you know like that's why i said
[ __ ] the noise because it's like if
don't focus on what they want you to
focus on focus on why they're doing what
they're doing now do you know how much
manpower it takes for someone to go
through every single episode of the jre
they probably had a whole team on that
[ __ ]
and just like find where he was saying
the word find where he was using the n
word and just like they would have had
like 10 people on that [ __ ] yeah and
hours of [ __ ] footage and it's like
why now why now
and i'm like you i'm not saying think
like me just use your brain so when that
guy tried to ask i saved dana's ass by
the
way
he was trying to set dana up yeah and no
i didn't mean to i was just like this
[ __ ] because first off it's like
i know rogan and his apology was first
of all the thing he um was the country
singer's name that he um talked about um
when he made that first video
neil young and he's just like i watched
that back on spotify by the way yeah oh
really didn't mind
it's like the certain songs that he
doesn't have
when he made that video i was kind of
like man he handled that really nicely
told his new neil young story yeah and
he wasn't even mad he and i'm like
that's that's how you handle that and
then when that video came out i haven't
watched the video because i don't give a
[ __ ] yeah not that yeah he was wrong you
know he shouldn't have said that and he
said he was wrong and he said i'm sorry
i'm like that was the most sincere not
like scripted hollywood my manager wrote
this down for me to like apologize i'm
like what more do you want yeah and it's
just this [ __ ] culture of just like
nah we're gonna hold you to your past no
that's how many years ago and he he
admitted like yeah i didn't think this
was ever going to happen i was not this
i was just paraphrasing and this and
that so for me when i when i heard that
i was like look let me handle this and i
just
said it how it is you know yeah [ __ ] the
noise because we know what they do he's
got the biggest platform right now yeah
on earth yeah and he's not able to be
controlled so the people the powers that
be are like you know what let's what's
next there's going to be something gotta
you know transgender this or they'll try
and find that and after that that
doesn't work then they're gonna go try
and find something from his past where
it's like oh you know back in 1990 you
know you know he and it's like yeah it's
amazing people eat cockroaches exactly
i can't steal will yeah but like i mean
yeah it's a systematic way of trying to
take power away from someone yes people
are starting to like pre that but you
you get the most scrutiny for it because
you're defending a white dude that's
saying this word that no white dude
should say yeah but i'm just curious
like did you get a lot of pushback did
you find most people be supportive no i
didn't i didn't really hear anything for
me it's i i speak my truth you know i'm
just like you know what this
he said sorry let it go i know the guy
he's the he's the nicest [ __ ] in
the game he's a cool dude on and off
screen he's a cool [ __ ] so yeah
if they want i mean there's no pushback
there's nothing like i said i wish they
would i'm not i'm not a saint i'm not a
president i'm not nothing i can say
whatever the [ __ ] i want i fight people
for money that's my job
don't take me seriously don't take me
seriously like i'm some kind of
candidate for whatever like just yeah
speak my truth yeah you're um
you're a free dude
freestyle vendor is an interesting name
yeah because
to me it's not like free like you don't
have to pay for it but it's like
it was meant to be an only fan so see
the plan was
the plan was yes
see the plan was i was like you know
what
everything i'm doing on youtube right
now was meant to be on only fans and
that was the plan but then only fans is
banned in
china it's abandoned dubai uae has
banned in nigeria and i'm like these are
key markets for me i need my my content
to get out i still post on there once in
a while i made it free now yeah like the
first month i made like 10k you know
yeah just off like a low subscription
and i kind of put some stuff out there
but then i just made it free because i'm
not gonna like screw people out of this
so then i put everything from there that
i was going to do on youtube and and
it's killing yeah we're doing well no no
you're killing it very well i just i
just like it because
the idea of freestyling i see you as a
very uh liberated dude and by liberated
i mean like you've created your own
identity yes and my own character your
own character
which is rare
but like there's there's certain people
like throughout history especially kind
of famous people are usually tied to
institutions right and like like i
always think of mike tyson as being
bigger than any other identity
like mike tyson is mike tyson that's him
exactly he's not black guy that's a
boxer he's not guy from brooklyn he's
not you know guy who trained under
customer it's like mike tyson is this
unique individual and he can have his
own opinion charles barkley is another
one like there are these certain p these
certain figures that are just like these
like
unique human beings
snoop is another one yeah you know and
we're like naming all black guys right
now
is there a white guy
well no but rogan's a little bit like
another thing is like as white you don't
as white like when you're living in a
predominantly white place you don't have
to like you're kind of looked at as what
is quote normal so you don't have to opt
out of identity but there absolutely are
those types like you know maybe kurt
cobain like these kind of like rockstar
types um
and i just i just really admire that
trajectory that you're going on because
you are free to say what you want to say
yeah as long as it's being authentic to
you yeah and a lot of people are
terrified of doing it because they're
worried about losing out on what was the
one i had i want to say something that
never really got out there um you
retweeted something oh it was a joke on
twitter
ah shoot your shot
so you said something about yeah
remember that okay so there was
something that happened behind the
scenes there was something that happened
behind the scenes i can't remember the
joke
yeah man so he made a joke on twitter
right because i don't even tweet his
[ __ ] back to him i just i i'll just text
you yeah because
and i'm the wild guy
but um he made a joke right you made a
joke about something this is mma fans
and
between mma fans and school scooters
and i was like mma fans
what did i say mma fans shooter shoot
just sh i can't remember how it is find
the tweet find the tweet you put it on
the thing but yeah anyway i then got a
call from tim like yo you got to take
that i'm like i'm not taking that down
yeah i was i'm not taking that down i
was like no because this is that this
and that red red raw i've got two
companies emailing me or i was like what
did i say i just retweeted andrew's joke
and i added a nice tag line i thought it
was funny as [ __ ] yeah you know me okay
you got it mma fans just talk about how
they're a badass blue belt and they
could be in the ufc right now blah blah
blah
school shooters at least know how to dot
that dot
that's a good tag line that's funny as
[ __ ] i thought it was a good tag line
and then
there it is oh yeah yeah and then and
then behind the scenes then then i was
just i told tim i was just like i'm not
deleting this i'm not because then
you know they went he's like who's then
i just i went on this tangent look at
his next tweet this ain't getting
deleted
facts and people you read the comments
and stuff that i'm i'm coming back when
this is deleted i'm good i'm like nah
[ __ ] you like because i'm sick of this
[ __ ] yeah i'm sick of this whole culture
of just like people trying to like
you made a joke that's not your people
i'm like [ __ ] people make jokes all the
time yeah it's the intent yes i'm not
saying i'm not praising dylan ruth and
saying you know bravo yeah something
like that [ __ ] um what's his name
trayvon martin oh not trevor mine what's
the guy's name zimmerman he's trying to
sue his family or something yeah i'm not
trying to praise those guys i just made
a tagline that was funny yeah and i'm
i don't care if i don't have that cloak
of being a comedian yeah i'm like i hit
and miss sometimes but i'm allowed to
try yeah you know what i mean and i i've
got some some stuff i don't even tweet
because i'm just like you know what i'm
putting this i need to see your drafts
yeah i just like you know what this
can you guys put him on stage for five
minutes that way he has full
carbohydrates
we gotta get you on stage
[Applause]
you